MAYOR OF MOSCOW’S WIFE?
THE ANSWER AHEAD.
BUT FIRST, GOODBYE MR. NICE GUY.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
SO OLD JOE CALLED A LEAD EARLY
THIS EVENING, MEANING HE’S NOT
MAKING ANY PUBLIC APPEARANCES
UNTIL THE DEBATE ON THURSDAY
NIGHT.
BUT COME ON, IT DOESN’T REALLY
MATTER.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO ENTHUSIASM
ANYWAY FOR BIDEN OUT THERE.
UNLESS YOU CALL THIS ENTHUSIASM.
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN.
I AM A CAR GUY.
I GOT A 67 CORVETTE THAT’S --
THAT’S NOT UP ’67, THAT’S A
427.
AT THAT THING GET DON MIKE GETS
UP AND GOES.
YOU MUST BE FREEZING.
FREEZING TO DEATH.
>> Laura: OH, MY.
TO PROP HIM UP TO CREATE A
VENEER OF ENERGY, WHILE HIS BIG
DONORS HAD TO FUND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGNS IN
HUMAN HISTORY.
AFTER BEING CALLED OUT AND
EXPOSED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
FAKE NEWS, THE DOMINANT MEDIA
WAS HAPPY TO OBLIGE BY
AMPLIFYING THE CAMPAIGN PITCH.
IT REALLY THE ONE THAT THEY HAVE
WHICH IS THAT BY THEN, IF YOU
LET HIM, HE WILL GET US BACK TO
NORMAL.
AFTER ALL, HE IS SO NICE.
>> NORMALCY, THAT SEEMS TO BE A
BIG PART OF THE PITCH THAT
JOE BIDEN IS SOMEBODY WHO WILL
ALLOW THE COUNTRY TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY.
>> LET’S GET BACK TO NORMAL,
STEADY THE SHIP.
TO SPEAK OF THIS IS A DECENCY
CHECK ON THIS PRESIDENT.
>> JOE BIDEN IS PRESENTING A
PLAN TO GET TO THE COLUMN.
>> Laura: .COM?
[LAUGHS]
THE DIGNIFIED GRANDFATHER
CHASING AROUND HIS GRANDKIDS ALL
OVER THE YARD.
BOY, DO THEY THINK THAT YOU ARE
STUPID OR WHAT?
IT’S ALL BEING PRESENTED AS ALL
BEING FRAMED THIS WAY TO THROW
YOU OFF THE SCENT OF WHAT’S
REALLY TO COME.
PUNISHMENT.
THOSE RUNNING THE JOE SHOW HAS
ALWAYS HATED MIDDLE AMERICA.
THAT’S WHY HE IS THE PERFECT
CANDIDATE.
KIND OF A TROJAN HORSE FROM THE
OLD, SLIGHTLY MORE MODERATE
PARTY TO PUSH THEIR RADICAL
POLICY.
THE MARKETING OF BIDEN AS THIS
NICE, NORMAL GUY WAS FUNDED AND
PROMOTED BY SOME OF THE MOST
RUTHLESS, THE RICHEST PEOPLE IN
BUSINESS, THE MEDIA, AND
ENTERTAINMENT.
AND ONCE THEY GET PAST THE
ELECTION IT IS PAYBACK TIME.
FORMER LABOR SECRETARY ROBERT
RICE AND OTHER LIBERALS ARE
PUSHING FOR SOMETHING CALLED A
TRUTH AND RECONCILIATION
COMMISSION.
WHEN THIS NIGHTMARE IS OVER, IT
WILL ERASE TRUMP LIES, COMFORT
THOSE BEING HARMED BY HIS
HATEFULNESS, AND NAME EVERY
OFFICIAL, POLITICIAN, EXECUTIVE,
AND MEDIA MOGUL WHO HAS ENABLED
THIS CATASTROPHE.
WELL, THE MORE RECENT
INSPIRATION FOR ALL OF THIS GOES
BACK TO THE AIR IN SOUTH AFRICA.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU VOTED FOR
OR EVER SUPPORTED TRUMP YOU ARE
KNOW BETTER THAN THE PEOPLE WHO
THROUGH NELSON MANDELA IN PRISON
PRISON.
THE INTIMIDATION SLOT HAS BEEN
HARD AT WORK IN RECENT DAYS.
CHECK WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY
FREE SPEECH RALLY IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
[SHOUTING]
>> BACKUP!
>> Laura: THE HANDIWORK
AGAINST THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
ORGANIZER WAS ALL MESSED UP
FRONT TEETH.
THEY BEAT HIM IN THE FACE.
THESE ARE THE NICE PEOPLE
SUPPORTING JOE.
NOW BIDEN -- I THINK HE SOLD, HE
SOLD AS A GUY WHO CARES ABOUT
THE KIDS.
THE TEACHER UNION ALLIES FIGHT
TO KEEP THESE KIDS LOCKED IN
VIRTUAL LEARNING THAT IS A REAL
WORLD DISASTER.
INCLUDING WHEN A STUDENT HAS A
TRUMP FLAG IN THE BACKGROUND
DURING ONE OF THOSE HIDEOUS
ZUMBA CLASSES.
>> ANTHONY RIBEIRO SAYS HE
LOGGED INTO CHEMISTRY CLASS LAST
WEEK FROM HOME WHEN WHAT’S
BEHIND HIM QUICKLY BECAME A
PROBLEM.
THE CHEMISTRY TEACHER ASKED THEM
TO REMOVE HIS TRUMP FLAG.
>> HE SAID IF YOU WILL NOT TAKE
IT DOWN, UNACCEPTABLE AND I WILL
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO LEAVE THE
CLASSROOM.
AT THAT POINT I WAVED GOODBYE
WAVED GOODBYE.
>> HE SAID IT HAPPENED A SECOND
TIME IN A DIFFERENT CLASS THE
NEXT DAY.
HE SAID HE TOOK THE FLAG DOWN
THAT TIME WORRYING IT MAY START
TO AFFECT HIS GRADES.
>> Laura: SMART KID.
THESE ARE TRULY AWFUL PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THE SO-CALLED CHAMPIONS
OF DIVERSITY WHO WANT TO CANCEL
YOU, FRIGHTEN YOU, AND EVEN
SCARIER CHILDREN FROM HOLDING
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
OF COURSE, ON POLICY BIDEN WILL
OVERSEE AN UNENDING SERIES OF
THESE TYPES OF PUNISHMENTS, BUT
A LOT WORSE.
THEY INTEND TO PACK THE COURTS,
MAKE D.C. A STATE, RAISE YOUR
TAXES, OUTLAW YOUR GUNS, FLED
THE COUNTRY WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, JUST TO NAME A FEW.
AND OF COURSE USING COVID AS
COVER, INSTILL DRACONIAN LAWS
NATIONWIDE.
ALL SO THEY CAN RESET THINGS
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
TAKE POWER BACK FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS ISN’T GOING TO BE A
GOVERNMENT OF BY AND FOR THE
PEOPLE.
NO WAY.
IT’S GOING TO BE A GOVERNMENT
OF, BY, AND FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
BEHAVE.
WHO DON’T ROCK THE BOAT.
WHO DON’T QUESTION OUR TRADE
POLICY, OUR HEALTH CARE POLICY,
GOVERNMENT-FUNDED ABORTION, OUR
MILITARY EXPENDITURES OVER SEES,
IF YOU GATHERED TO PROTEST, THEY
WILL PUNISH YOU AS WELL.
THEY MIGHT EVEN PUT YOU IN JAIL.
THE BIDEN PUPPETEERS WANT THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY TO BE LIKE
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE THE PEOPLE IN THOSE
STATES SO WELL-TRAINED THEY
DIDN’T PROTEST IN ANY LARGE
NUMBERS, EVEN AFTER ALL THOSE
PEOPLE DIED NEEDLESSLY IN
RETIREMENT HOMES.
AFTER ALL OF THOSE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS.
THE BILLIONAIRES LEVITATING
BIDEN TO ELECTION DAY AND THE
ELITES IN THE UNITED STATES
MEDIA -- THEY ALWAYS VIEW TRUMPS
AMERICA AS A SORT OF UP PEASANTS
REVOLT, EVEN THOUGH IT WAS RUN
BY BILLIONAIRE TRUMP.
THESE TITANS OF SILICON VALLEY,
THEY CERTAINLY DON’T WANT TO
HAVE TO RAISE THIS MUCH MONEY
EVERY FOUR YEARS.
THE PUNISHMENTS BOTH CARRIED OUT
AND THREATENED ARE ALSO DESIGNED
TO SCARE OFF ANY OTHER RICH GUY
OR GAL FOR TRYING TO DO WHAT
TRUMP TRIED AGAIN.
NO OTHER FIRST FAMILY HAS
ENDURED WITH THE TRUMP FAMILY
HAS.
ALL THE LIES, THE INSINUATIONS,
THE ACCUSATIONS, AND DEFAMATION.
HOW DARE THEY ENABLE A MAN WHO
RAN ON EXPOSING AND REVERSING
THE FAILED POLICIES OF NOT JUST
THE DEMOCRATS LIKE OBAMA AND THE
CLINTONS, BUT THE BUSHES AS WELL
WELL.
HOW DARE ALL OF YOU FOR ENABLING
NOT.
AND THE CLOSER WE GET TO THE
ELECTION, WE WILL HEAR A LOT
FROM THEIR ALLIES, LIKE
SOMETHING I HEARD TODAY.
CONGRESSMAN FRANCIS ROONEY FROM
THE OLD G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT HE
WAS INVITED ON CNN TO THROW
SHADE AT THE PRESIDENT TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> HAS BEEN WORTH IT FOR THE
JUDGES AND THE TAX CUTS?
>> THAT’S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE UNDERMINING
OF OUR BANKS AND THE THREATS TO
OUR FUTURE AND YOU LOOK AT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED, A LOT OF SCAR TISSUE
THERE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO GOING FORWARD.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, THANKS FOR
YOUR DECENCY.
>> Laura: THE QUESTION WAS
"WAS IT WORTH IT ELECTING
TRUMP?"
HE SAYS THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION?
WHAT?
HOW EXACTLY DID TRUMP UNDERMINE
THE BASE CONGRESSMAN ROONEY WHO
IS RETIRING THANKFULLY.
BEFORE THEN, THE G.O.P. HAD NOT
WON ANY GENERAL ELECTION SINCE
2004.
HE BROUGHT BACK THE BLUE-COLLAR
VOTERS AND NOW HE’S BRINGING IN
LATINOS TOO.
THE SCAR TISSUE CONGRESSMAN IS
WHAT THEY ARE LEFT WITH.
THEY WANT US TO EMBRACE, IN THE
END, A FALSE SENSE OF DECENCY
WITH BIDEN.
A FAKE DIGNITY BEING PEDDLED BY
A MAN WHO DESPITE HIS GRANDPA
JOE ACT IS STILL JUST NASTY JOE
FROM SCRANTON.
>> I HAVE NO RESPONSE, IT’S
ANOTHER SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
RIGHT UP YOUR ALLEY, IT’S THE
QUESTIONS YOU ALWAYS ASK.
>> CALM DOWN, IT’S OKAY.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE TOO OLD TO VOTE FOR ME.
>> Laura: TOTAL FRAUD.
THE NORMAL SEE THE LEFT CRAVES,
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT NORMAL
MEANS FOR THEM.
YOU ARE TOTALLY GOING TO GET
YOUR HEALTH CARE AND ONE WHERE
YOUR SPEECH IS STIFLED ALONG
WITH THE RELIGIOUS PRACTICE.
IF THAT IS THE KIND OF DECENCY,
IF THAT’S THE KIND OF RETURN TO